[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
édition du Grand JT des territoires
voici tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité une baguette à 1,50 € et si
cela devenait bientôt une réalité et
boulangers sont eux aussi fragilisées
par l'envoler des prix de l'énergie et
de l'ordre reportage et explications à
suivre dès le début de cette édition
avec Vosges télévision octobre rose
c'est jusqu'à la fin du mois l'opération
de communication autour du dépistage du
cancer du sein est organisé partout en
France chaque année ses 12000 femmes qui
décèdent de ce cancer dans notre pays la
prévention est évidemment essentielle et
notamment dans les quartiers
prioritaires nous montrera via Occitanie
les produits LVMH font rêver le monde
entier vers l'outil Dior ou encore
Guerlain alors bonne nouvelle les
ateliers des plus grandes marques du
groupe seront ouvertes au public à
partir du 14 octobre et à cette occasion
Antoine Arnaud nous a accordé un
entretien exceptionnel à Paris vous en
découvrirez un extrait en avant-première
dans ce journal du rêve encore en fin
d'édition avec un reportage de LM TV
Sarthe sur la passion d'une enseignante
pour l'aéronautique une passion vous le
verrez qu'elle transmet à ses élèves
particulièrement aux jeunes filles
je vous le disais dans les titres
faudra-t-il bientôt débourser un euro 50
pour ce pays une baguette à tel montant
était jusqu'à lors inimaginable mais la
question se pose aujourd'hui face à la
hausse du coût des matières premières et
des prix de l'énergie certaines
boulangeries ne parviennent plus à être
rentable et sont ainsi obligés
d'augmenter à leur tour les prix de
leurs produits pour survivre explication
chez un boulanger avec Anthony Sapp et
Anne Didier de Vosges télévision
regardez
et si demain le prix de la baguette
augmentait une question que les
boulangers se posent souvent par les
temps qui courent avec la hausse du coût
des matières premières et les prix de
l'énergie qui s'envolent certaines
enseignes ne sont actuellement plus
rentables
s'il vous plaît les coups de boutoir
successifs Après le covid sur
l'augmentation en premier de la farine
ça c'est fait 1 + 25 de locotation de
toutes les matières premières et ce qui
a annoncé pour la fin de l'année
c'est-à-dire le doublement du prix du
beurre du sucre etc et bien sûr le
l'augmentation faramineuse même rielle
de l'énergie qui s'annonce Sébastien
Pinault travaille à son compte depuis 22
ans il a ouvert 6 boulangeries dans le
département dont celle-ci a Remiremont
avec bien sûr quelques emplois à la clé
mais cette année il a vu sa facture
annuelle d'électricité doublée et la
tendance devrait être la même en 2023 en
2022 ça représente une augmentation de
70 000 euros quand même donc c'est c'est
énorme et en 2023 et en 2023 bah 140000
euros aujourd'hui les boulangeries de
moins de 10 salariés bénéficient du
bouclier tarifaire du gouvernement la
Fédération demande donc un élargissement
aux structures plus importantes pour
éviter les fermetures et en attendant
toutes ces hausses de charges devrait se
répercuter sur les prix des produits
c'est inilitable il me semble que toute
façon aujourd'hui le pain augmentera le
prix du pain en effet augmentera lui qui
est en France une référence monétaire il
n'échappera pas à l'inflation surtout
que dans cette baguette on retrouve le
travail du boulanger mais aussi celui du
meunier et avant lui celui du producteur
de céréales un circuit court qui tente
tant bien que mal de résister à une
tempête économique mondiale
voilà et il n'y a bien sûr pas que les
petits commerces qui souffrent dans ce
contexte mais aussi les collectivités
les mers notamment qui cherchent par
tous les moyens à réaliser des économies
exemple à Grenoble ou la ville réemploi
l'eau de l'une de ses piscines
municipales à des fins d'arrosage et de
nettoyage une bonne initiative pour le
budget communal mais aussi pour
l'environnement sujet de Charlotte
folkner pour Télé Grenoble
après avoir rafraîchi près de 51 000
grenoblois tous l'été l'eau de la
piscine jambon va de nouveau servir
cette fois-ci pour les espaces verts et
publics une solution inédite
expérimentée par la Ville de Grenoble
depuis la fin de l'été si l'eau à cette
couleur verte c'est que les services
sont attendus que tout le chlore
s'évapore avant de pouvoir lui donner
une seconde vie alors là aujourd'hui
c'est les balayeuses qui qui prennent
l'eau de la piscine pour aller nettoyer
les rues nettoyer les marchés en
particulier c'est aussi des espaces
verts ça tourne pourraient servir à
arroser les les arbres en moyenne ce
sont près de 50 mètres cubes qui sont
utilisés quotidiennement par les
services de la ville pour l'arrosage des
espaces verts ou encore le nettoyage des
rues et des espaces publics des besoins
en eau qui varient en fonction des
périodes de l'année les besoins sont
essentiellement sur le service nature en
ville pour les citernes pour l'arrosage
des massifs et des jeunes armes et le
service de la propreté urbaine pour le
remplissage en fait des balayeuses les
petites balayeuses font 2 mètres cubes
les grosses balayeuses font 8 mètres
cubes ils ont différents besoins donc
ils viennent autant que autant qu'ils
veulent en fait réutiliser l'eau des
piscines une expérimentation qui soulève
d'autres questions une fois par an les
piscines doivent obligatoirement être
vidangés une réglementation que la
municipalité soit très revoir on est
capable et on sait
on s'est entretenir et on s'est vérifié
la qualité de l'eau pour cette phase
d'expérimentation ce sont près de 300
mètres cubes sur les 2500 de la piscine
jambon qui seront utilisés par les
services de la ville
voilà et du côté des plus petites
communes on se montre aussi innovants
pour préserver les bourses en Savoie une
ville de 5000 habitants a décidé de
prendre les devants en adoptant un plan
de sobriété une initiative qui doit lui
permettre d'éviter d'augmenter les
impôts locaux ou de réduire les services
images et précision du maire au micro de
Sébastien Germain journaliste pour la
chaîne 8 Mont-Blanc sur place
on estime en tout cas pour 2023 avoir
une hausse de 70% sur le gaz une hausse
très conséquente x 2 x 3 pour le prix de
l'électricité et c'est comme si en tout
cas progrès surex on augmentait le
budget de fonctionnement de 7%, c'est
représentent entre 200 à 300000 euros
tous les ans cette somme nous n'en
disposons pas l'action qui va être le
plus visible vis-à-vis de la population
c'est de l'extinction de l'éclairage
public à partir de 21h30 jusqu'à 6h pour
les zones résidentielles 22h30 jusqu'à
6h pour les routes départementales on va
dire structuant du bas de la commune
après on a la sobriété vis-à-vis du gaz
à travers une baisse de chauffage sur la
totalité de nos bâtiments d'un degré la
remise en route du chauffage justement
vous êtes nombreux à la faire en ce mois
d'octobre quand les températures
baissent octobre c'est aussi un mois
rose dédié à la communication autour du
cancer du sein en France seule la moitié
des femmes concernées ont participé à un
dépistage de ce cancer l'an dernier un
chiffre encore insuffisant et une
problématique particulièrement tenace
dans les quartiers dit prioritaires où
il est peut-être difficile d'accéder à
des professionnels de santé anime la
mairie a décidé de réagir et de cibler
précisément ces quartiers pour inciter
aux dépistage reportage de Lorie
chamerla pour via Occitanie
des petits gâteaux et des inscriptions
arabes la ville de Nîmes LANSA campagne
pour Octobre Rose le mois de
sensibilisation pour le cancer du sein
et du col de l'utérus dans les quartiers
prioritaires le stand d'information est
tenu par des bénévoles d'humanisme une
association très implantée à Val de Gour
il y a pas beaucoup d'épaissage sur le
quartier parce qu'en fait il y a pas une
information ciblée sur sur les personnes
qui sont concernées sachant qu'il y a
des habitants qui ne lisent pas
forcément le français ou nous ne
comprennent pas donc on a on a essayé de
mettre en place un affichage sur
plusieurs langues adaptées à la
population du quartier c'est tout
l'intérêt de s'appuyer sur des acteurs
du quartier une fois le contact établi
les femmes sont invitées à développer le
sujet avec une conseillère en pharmacie
pour des informations précises sur le
dépistage ça c'est les palpations
donc ils s'intéresse pas donc ou bien il
trouve pas quelqu'un qui le retourne des
conseils
non pour moi tous les deux ans je fais
une échographie
non pas encore pourquoi c'est quoi le
frein
j'avais pas le temps parce que j'étais
malade et là je vais le faire le
dépistage c'est tous les deux ans pour
le cancer du sein et tous les trois ans
pour celui du col de l'utérus tous deux
sont remboursés à 100% par l'Assurance
Maladie des informations encore
méconnues dans le quartier une étude de
la RS en 2013 morte et montrer
effectivement qu'il y avait quand dirait
une grosse problématique en matière
dépistage dans ce quartier mais aussi
dans d'autres quartiers la ville de
Nîmes a ciblé les quartiers prioritaires
de Pissevin masse de Mingue et Val de
Gour pour y renforcer la campagne
d'Octobre rose
voilà et sachez que le cancer du sein
peut être guéri dans 9 cas sur 10 si il
est dépisté assez tôt les répercussions
physiques et psychologiques n'en reste
pas moins importante pour les femmes
atteintes et c'est pour les aider à se
reconstruire qu'une association leur
propose des tatouages artistiques
objectifs relevez la tête malgré les
cicatrices et la douleur images et
propos récolter par Alexis cada pour la
rédaction de TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest à Bordeaux dans la
reconstruction
par rapport au cancer c'est vraiment
c'est moi qui décide c'est moi qui
prends le contrôle
pour faire quelque chose de joli de ce
qu'on m'a pris en fait non c'est
important et puis surtout c'est hyper
facile pour nous parce que ça nous
demande juste un dessin une journée et
quel bonheur on donne en retour contre
un peu de temps et un peu d'encre
du courage au féminin dans cette édition
avec le portrait d'une athlète au corps
sculpté par l'effort Muriel bovilain 50
ans participera le mois prochain au
championnats du monde de culturisme
naturel une pratique encore méconnue en
France et soumise à beaucoup de préjugés
et c'est pour en savoir un peu plus
justement sur cet univers musclé que la
rédaction de TV 78 dans les Yvelines a
suivi le temps d'un entraînement la
championne française un portrait signé
Julien Leroy
je vais commencer à 20 kg
et normalement les dernières c'est 28
voire 30 kilos encore une séance
intensive pour Muriel Beauvillain cette
yvelinoise originaire de mitainville
s'entraînait actuellement à Rambouillet
en vue du championnat du monde de
culturisme naturel la sportif de 50 ans
a été sacré deux fois vice championne de
France et trois fois viches championne
d'Europe depuis le mois de janvier je
suis en préparation on m'a dit que
j'étais qualifiée pour Europe et France
donc deux mois après encore de prépa et
là comme dit qu'on m'a dit que j'étais
sélectionné pour pour monde j'ai calculé
août septembre octobre novembre encore 4
mois de prépa j'ai fait aller on vit
qu'une fois Muriel développe sa passion
pour le culturisme après plusieurs
années de dépression son conjoint lui
fait découvrir cet univers et
l'encourage à se dépasser la sportive
décide de relever le défi voilà il m'a
embarqué là dedans moi j'y suis allé
parce que je suis une fonceuse la
championne se présentera dans 6
catégories différentes pour le
championnat du monde elle défilera en
robe de soirée dans la catégorie Miss
run away Muriel tient éloigner des
clichés autour du culturisme féminin
de casser les préjugés sur le fait qu'on
peut pas être musculaire et féminine le
regard des gens de façon qu'on fasse ça
fera parler qu'on fasse pas ça fera
parler la sportive exerce en parallèle
le métier d'auxiliaire de vie ses
responsable était d'abord surpris par
son physique atypique
volontiers que voilà c'est qu'une
apparence j'adore
m'occuper de ces personnes leur rendre
service être à leur à leur écoute le
championnat du monde de culturisme
naturel se tiendra à Prague les 18 et 19
novembre prochain la sportive a lancé
sur Internet une cagnotte litchi pour
l'aider à accomplir son rêve de médaille
eux n'ont peut-être pas tous un corps
parfait mais savent au moins communiquer
12 jeunes agriculteurs de la Somme ont
pris la pose dans leur plus simple
appareil pour promouvoir leur métier
résultat un calendrier façon dieu du
stade une action de communication bien
sûr dont une partie de la recette
permettra de soutenir les associations
locales reportage de Jérémie Houbron
pour oui au TV la chaîne du groupe La
Voix du Nord
la combinaison c'est une tenue de
travail normale pour Élie pourtant la
dernière fois que cette agriculteur a
posé devant un objectif c'était dans son
plus simple appareil
donc c'est oui ici au milieu des vaches
que la photo a eu lieu
le derrière dans la paille on va dire un
shooting photo façon dieu du stade pour
un calendrier ce n'est pas tellement
dans les habitudes du jeune éleveur
laitier alors forcément ça laisse
quelques souvenirs pour l'anecdote quand
ils sont venu faire les photos j'avais
mon apprenti qui était en train de
traire donc
voir son maître de stage tout nu bon
allez je lui avais dit reste dans la
salle de traite mais donc c'est vrai que
c'était un peu insolite sur le moment
c'est pas faire attention quoi comme lui
11 agriculteurs ça m'a rien se sont
prêtés au jeu des photos en tenue d'Adam
ça rend bien ah ouais trop beau si le
projet germé depuis plusieurs années
dans la tête des jeunes agriculteurs de
la somme il a fallu un an de travail
avant d'en récolter le fruit aujourd'hui
2000 exemplaires sont imprimés c'était
de faire quelque chose de décalé mais
pas dans la vulgarité ça reste très soft
on voit rien du tout ça montre à travers
toutes les photos qui qui représentent
enfin toutes les cultures tous les
élevages qu'on a dans le département
c'était holiday aussi de mettre
l'agriculture sa Marienne en avant une
campagne de communication à la fois
insolite et solidaire pour chaque
calendrier vendu un euro sera reversé à
l'association Solal qui facilite les
dons de la filière agricole vers les
associations d'aide alimentaire
voilà restons au naturel dans ce journal
pour parler désormais de la protection
des forêts un enjeu majeur pour
l'environnement qui amène à découvrir
d'anciennes pratiques parmi celles-ci le
débardage à cheval soit le transport du
bois après son avatar sans recourir aux
machines cette technique permet de
préserver les sols et l'environnement de
la forêt explications de la rédaction de
Canal 32 dans l'Aube
pour avancer on dit U pour reculer recul
à droite on a un dialecte belge on dit
mieux lieu à droite et à gauche malgré
son poids de 900 kg le conservatoire de
littoral et l'OF ont choisi d'utiliser
le cheval plutôt que des engins pour
éviter les conséquences à long terme du
tassement des sols les racines d'un
arbre s'enfonce parfois seulement de 30
cm la l'empreinte du cheval on voit bien
il y a même pas un centimètre de plus là
vous voyez on est passé sur l'arbre
là-bas on est passé de chaque côté
l'arbre il n'est pas frotté il y a pas
de danger pour l'arbre qui est resté en
place les premières pluies comme
aujourd'hui et les premiers passages de
tracteurs on va vite s'embourber trouver
de la boue et de l'argile ou là on
pourrait détruire le sol et toute la le
potentiel de la parcelle en seulement
trois passages ce samedi les forestiers
sont invités à assister à des
démonstrations de débardage à cheval le
but les convaincre du bénéfice à très
long terme de préserver les sols et donc
le rendement de la parcelle ce jeudi les
élèves de l'école de mini-saint-père ont
été invités à découvrir ce métier rare
en fait c'est
[Musique]
ce qu'ils veulent
apprendre à l'écosystème de la forêt la
gestion des forêts les différents
métiers de la forêt je crois que Gabin
était la star aujourd'hui
de cette sortie le remplacement du
cheval par des machines à entraîner la
quasi disparition de certaines races
locales cette activité de débardage
participent à leur conservation en
premier le Boulonnais et puis le Trait
du Nord mais le Boulonnais vraiment je
veux pas dire en voie de disparition
mais on pourrait presque le dire il y a
très très peu de naissances par an sera
mise à contribution durant une quinzaine
de jours dans les forêts du parc naturel
avant d'intervenir sur d'autres
chantiers
voilà la protection de l'environnement
qui passe aussi par la protection des
eaux en Bretagne la brigade nautique de
la gendarmerie a pour mission notamment
d’extraire de l'eau des épaves et des
bateaux coulés une tâche vous allez le
voir qui s'avère compliqué et très
coûteux objectif d'ici la fin de l'année
recyclé mille bateaux clairs Grillot
pour la rédaction locale de TVA à Rennes
maintenant tu prends tes deux têtes
voilà et tu viens mettre ça
plusieurs heures ont été nécessaires
pour extraire de l'eau ce voilier de 8
mètres entièrement couler comme ce
bateau 22 épaves abandonnés ont été
sortis cette semaine de l'estuaire de la
Vilaine propriétés de la région Bretagne
on s'appuie sur les élus locaux et
notamment les mers pour qu'ils puissent
dresser des arrêtés de péril une fois
que l'arrêté de péril est dressée ça
nous permet nous de retirer le bateau et
ensuite de faire un dépôt de plainte et
de rechercher le propriétaire pour
recouvrer les sommes que l'on a engagées
environ 1500 euros pour l'enlèvement
puis 1500 euros pour la déconstruction
dans un centre agréé la brigade nautique
de la gendarmerie est alors compétente
pour retirer les épaves de la Vilaine
mais aussi
identifier les propriétaires de bateaux
comme ça
nous essayons de retrouver les
propriétaires des bateaux à partir des
indices que vont nous fournir les
bateaux soit un nombre bateau soit une
immatriculation soit un modèle de bateau
nous verrons avec le procureur de la
République de Vannes si nous engageons
des poursuites à l'encontre des
propriétaires pour des abandons d'épaves
les bateaux sont constitués de résine de
plastique
c'est pas voilà c'est dans la nature
c'est des pollutions en partenariat avec
l'Association pour la plaisance et
co-responsable la région Bretagne
poursuit sa campagne unique en France et
baptisé mille bateaux recyclés jusqu'au
31 décembre les coups de transport et de
démantèlement des bateaux de plaisance
hors d'usage sont gratuits pour les
propriétaires qui en font la demande sur
recycler mon bateau.fr
qui n'a pas rêvé de pouvoir visiter les
ateliers de Louis Vuitton de Dior ou de
Chaumet et bien chaque année les marques
emblématiques du groupe LVMH ouvrent
leur porte au public lors des Journées
Particulières les 14 15 et 16 octobre
prochain vous pourrez donc pousser les
portes des adresses les plus
confidentielles du monde les ateliers de
couture les domaines viticoles en
passant par les grands magasins ou la
haute joaillerie tout vous sera dévoilé
et pour cette cinquième édition je vous
propose d'écouter celui qui est à
l'origine de cet événement Antoine
Arnault Il nous a accueilli dans les
ateliers de la maison Dior à Paris
regardez un extrait de cet entretien
exclusif
on veut que cette édition soit axée sur
d'être un peu la surprise proposer des
des master class original proposé
quelque chose de différent des éditions
précédentes et enfin axé sur l'humain
c'est vrai qu'après ces deux années de
pandémie après aussi plein de
conversations
sur le metaves sur les NFT sur les
avatars la cette fois on sera en tête à
tête comme nous aujourd'hui les yeux
dans les yeux et les spectateurs
pourront discuter avec les artisans avec
une forte empreinte régionale aussi dans
les territoires les ateliersh du groupe
un peu partout en France c'est vrai et
qui reste fortement bien sûr bien sûr
des centaines d'ateliers et pour toutes
nos maisons ou presque alors on va dire
que on est un maison on est un groupe
international avec une un vrai
barycentre français et un petit peu
italien on a beaucoup de maisons
italienne aussi qui propose des produits
de maroquinerie des souliers
des produits de joaillerie aussi
pour l'une des activités alors oui moi
je suis PDG de Berluti depuis une
dizaine d'années aussi maintenant et je
dois dire que aller visiter les ateliers
sur mesure de berlotti rue Marbeuf cette
fois-ci cette année aussi on ouvre pour
la première fois l'atelier tailleur sur
mesure qui est rue de Sèvres ça vaut
vraiment le coup voilà et notez donc
dans vos agendas que vous pourrez
visiter les ateliers des plus grandes
marques du groupe LVMH au cours de ces
journées particulières les 14 15 et 16
octobre prochain toutes les infos sont à
retrouver sur le site les journées
particulières.com que vous voyez
s'afficher sur cet écran enfin sachez
aussi que l'entretien d'Antoine Arnault
sera à découvrir entièrement lors du
prochain numéro de l'émission territoire
de France une émission diffusée sur TV5
Monde également
y a-t-il un âge pour se rendre au musée
à Limoges la réponse semblait évidente
c'est non dans la cité de la porcelaine
les plus petits découvrent des
collections adaptées à leur âge au sein
du musée des Beaux-Arts accompagné
notamment d'une animatrice culturelle
les enfants apprennent ainsi à éveiller
leur sens au contact de matière et de
couleur et dans un lieu étonnant pour
eux les explications au micro d'Alan
Druot de la rédaction de cet animal sur
place
il découvre un autre univers c'est une
immersion dans un musée ici c'est un
très beau lieu ancien et découvre des
salles très différentes donc c'est un
découvert des sens une découverte alors
après avec différents ateliers de la
matière découvrir les couleurs découvrir
notre lieu avec avec leur assistante
maternelle on improvise tous ensemble
j'allais dire avec les assistantes
maternelles et avec les enfants on est
petit on voit plus les choses du tout de
la même façon et puis aussi on peut plus
vraiment se mettre à leur place donc on
essaye de faire avec avec leur propre
regard
le regard des petits à la découverte des
Beaux-Arts celui des plus grands tournés
vers le ciel au Mans la passion pour
l'aéronautique se conjugue au féminin
grâce à l'implication d'une enseignante
son nom Corinne Herbelin pilote engagé
elle partage son amour pour le vol avec
ses élèves et un site les filles sous
représentées dans le secteur a passé
leur brevet de pilotes en contre lors de
la fête de l'aviation à l'aérodrome du
Mans avec ce sujet de Laurent Girard
pour LM télé Sarthe
Eva 13 ans rêve du ciel elle souhaite en
faire son métier alors la fête de
l'aviation aérodrome le mont Arnage et
l'occasion pour elle de s'initier au vol
en ULM ici un autogire parce que j'aime
bien c'est le fait de voler justement
parce que depuis tout petit mon rêve bah
le super pouvoir que j'aimerais avoir
justement c'est de voler et pour
apprendre elle peut compter sur son
enseignante Corinne Herbelin et pilote
instructrice du LM mais surtout elle
donne de son temps aux jeunes
bénévolement pour leur transmettre son
savoir-faire une passion qui lui est
venue à la suite d'un simple baptême
comme celui qui a vécu Eva aujourd'hui
on s'est aperçu que c'était accessible
j'ai eu mon emporte de passagers les
passagers étaient très contents et je me
suis dit pourquoi pas continuer et
préparer la qualification instructeur
pour partager cette passion mais Corinne
va plus loin en 2017 elle crée l'option
BIA au collège Guillaume Apollinaire de
Bouloire un diplôme hom par l'Éducation
nationale le BIA ou brevet d'initiation
aéronautique est accessible dès la
cinquième de quoi créer des vocations
moi j'aimerais bien montrer que c'est
accessible en plus grand nombre surtout
les femmes qui n'osent pas et leur
montrer que c'est accessible et que
c'est que du bonheur de voir la Terre
vit en haut à ce jour on ne recense que
5 à 8% de femmes pilotes du LM en France
moins de 10% de femmes pilote de ligne
il faut dire que l'État français
n'autorise les femmes à devenir pilote
de ligne quand 1973 c'était totalement
interdit il fallait être de sexe
masculin pour suivre la formation pilote
de ligne alors que les femmes ont fait
partie des débuts de l'aviation
il y a eu des beaucoup de luttes pour
lequel puisse transporter des passagers
paroles de Christine Debouzy première
femme pilote d'A380 un argument de plus
pour Keva fasse de ses rêves aériens une
réalité
voilà intéressons-nous à présent à
d'autres pilotes qui roulent avec des
engins bien différents des voitures
télécommandées le département de la
Loire accueillait il y a quelques jours
la finale du championnat de France de
ces bolides sur un circuit en terre
comme vous le voyez sur ces images de
nos partenaires de TL7 la télévision de
la Loire les meilleurs pilotes se sont
affrontés aux commandes de leur machine
et à toute allure une course au format
miniature car ravi participant comme
spectateur qu'il soit petit ou grands
écoutez ces réactions au micro de la
rédaction de TL7 la chaîne de la Loire
ici faut savoir que c'est probablement
une des trois plus belles pistes en
Europe j'ai la chance à travers mon
métier de voilà de voyager partout dans
le monde mais ici il a été mis beaucoup
d'efforts sur le tracé sur l'accueil sur
le le la qualité des sceaux la des
voitures qui vont qui tombent et qui
vont très vite
et ça fait du bruit oui
c'était original faire la sortie des
voitures télécommander
allez on referme ce journal avec un coup
d'oeil à l'édition spéciale de
l'hebdomadaire Le Point consacré cette
semaine à la ville de Strasbourg le
magazine revient notamment sur la
transformation en cours de la ville et
les nombreux défis qu'elle devra relever
à l'horizon de 2030 la mer écologiste de
la capitale européenne est également
interviewée dans cette édition locale
enfin le magazine vous dévoile également
10 adresses à connaître pour passer du
bon temps à Strasbourg entre escapade
gourmande culture sport ou encore
détente toutes ces informations sont
donc à relire dans l'édition spéciale du
point cette semaine voilà c'est la fin
de cette édition du Grand JT des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivis
on se retrouve très vite dans une
nouvelle édition on voit à tous
[Musique]